So today we've talking about understanding, which how agents make sense of
stories, events and other things in the world around them. We started off by
creating a more formal type of frame representation called thematic role
systems that captures verbs and tell us what to expect in certain events.
We then talked about how single verbs can actually have ambiguous meanings. But
thematic role frames can help us differentiate which meaning a verb has in
a particular sentence. Finally we talked about constraints and how
certain words or frames can constrain the possible meanings of a sentence and
help us figure out those ambiguous meanings. Today we've largely been talking
about how single words or phrases can have multiple possible meanings, but
next time we’ll do this in reverse. We’ll talk about how multiple words or
multiple phrases or multiple sentences can actually have the same meaning.
We'll talk about how we can discern that sameness, and then react accordingly